foreign
the title of the nature news article is
prior Omicron infection protects against
ba.4 and ba.5 variants
and uh and indeed what that entire
nature news article suggests is
precisely that that Omicron having been
infected with Omicron protects against
Omicron but having been protected
um having been infected with some a
variant that wasn't democrine doesn't
provide you uh much protection
but when you actually go to the research
as I did and I you know I did not do the
research I did not spend as much time as
I could with these papers but uh the
original research
doesn't say what it says it says as is
too often the case so let us go to this
is the alterane paper there's a couple
of papers here
um
this one and actually you can show my
screen here and again I'll link to the
the version of this is on the web but
I've got a PDF here uh this is this the
preprint that is primarily being
referred to in this nature news article
uh and the second author is the primary
author on the other pre-print so this is
a team out of cutter and they have
looked at at infections and basically
health records in Cutter that's how it's
pronounced right never never strikes me
as right uh which uh apparently you know
is a very unusual usual place uh with
something like gosh I forgot now but
um like closing in on 90 of the people
aren't from there and only less than 10
of the people are over 50. so it's you
know demographically very diverse in one
way but doesn't have very many old
people
so the title of this paper this preprint
uh which is the basis on which nature
news said Omicron previous infection
with Omicron provides immunity against
future infection with Omicron a previous
infection with non-elver cron doesn't do
you as much good
the title is protection of SARS cov2
natural infection against reinfection
with the Omicron B8 out for a B8 F5
subjects okay I'm going to scroll sorry
make you make you guys dizzy a little
bit here
um and in there this is what this is in
this the abstract
protection they say protection of a
previous infection against ba4 ba5
reinfection was modest when the previous
infection involved a pre-omicron variant
but strong when the previous infection
involved the Omicron ba.1 or b8.2
suburbance so that seems to be
consistent with what you were arguing
and what we might expect like we might
expect that if there really are distinct
differences between say Omicron and
Delta and the differences between
Omicron and Delta are greater than the
differences between Omicron ba1 and
Omicron ba5 that the natural immunity
that an infection would confer would be
greater the the more closely related the
the Infectious agents were to one
another you would expect that but what
did they do to assess this and sorry
again scrolling scrolling scrolling
this is in the methods
previous infections were classified as
pre-omicron versus Omicron previous
infections based on whether they
occurred before or after the Omicron
wave that started in Qatar in December
19 2021.
literally the only thing they did was
said if you were infected before
December 19th it must not have been
Omicron if you were infected after
December 19th it must be Omicron
there are two obvious problems with this
aside from no they didn't actually test
for whether or not Omicron was
conferring a natural immunity advantage
against Omicron they they did not do
that
one of the issues is of course we don't
we don't actually know what people were
infected with although presumably
Omicron wasn't circulating in say
December 2020 presumably but do we
really know that
um more to the point though what we
actually have here is a time stamp I
mean quite literally this is a time
stamp and so what they have found is the
totally obvious but apparently from you
know if you were listening to The Who
and the CDC for the last couple years
maybe they didn't quite track this thing
that we know from every other immune
response ever which is that the more
recently you've been exposed to the
pathogen the more likely you are to
maintain natural immunity to that
pathogen right if
so all we know in fact from this
research is the more recent your
exposure to covid the more likely you
are to maintain natural immunity to cope
it well I mean it I mean maybe I'm
missing something here but it just seems
especially in light of the fact that the
entire reason we're talking about
variance is that this thing is evolving
in real time right how can you do this
and just simply say after this date it
is X variant it's exactly the thing that
you would need to check in order to know
whether or not you were seeing
phenomenon a or phenomenon B yes are you
seeing escape from natural immunity or
are you seeing incompleteness of natural
immunity they're two distinct things and
there's no way to tell from this
research and what the editorial staff at
nature again one of the two premier
science journals in the entire world did
was take the abstract at face value and
not and again I didn't spend a ton of
time with this paper it didn't take much
and indeed nature news article does have
two virologists say that's good work but
there is this problem it's like well I
don't think that qualifies as good work
then so one one more thing oh no go on
well I just
want to point out there's something I
mean I think the most important thing
here is
the way nature is dealing with the world
of pre prints nature of the magazine not
nature the
well I guess nature the magazine is a
phenomenon but
um but nonetheless the
we are told that what makes it science
is peer review which is of course total
garbage right what makes it science is
the freaking method right that's what
makes it science peers to the extent
that they can do something they can
evaluate whether or not the method was
done correctly and whether or not the
things that you believe follow from your
evidence actually do follow from it that
is not inherent to peer review review by
peers does it also but there's something
fascinating about this nature so first
of all you probably in the audience will
not know unless you're a professional
scientist
that the people who staff these journals
see the Top Flight journals that make
and break careers right these people are
people who often did not succeed in
science itself right in other words they
have effectively left the rat race of
Academia and joined the rat race of the
journals which is a different game right
so I don't want to call them failed
academics but in some ways that's that's
partially what it is but the point is
okay these are the stewards of this
magical process we call peer review
right these are the peer-to-peers look
at what they do with an unpeer-reviewed
article first they grudgingly start
looking at this stuff which they should
have now what you and I have said about
the pre-print literature
non-peer-reviewed literature is that
it's very noisy right the quality varies
a lot that's natural because it hasn't
been through a filter in which people
will catch errors that said it is
distorted by the peer review process so
it's not obvious that more noise is
inherently bad if it comes with also
more signal because inconvenient truths
haven't been excluded for example right
so there is value in that pre-print
literature precisely because it hasn't
been put through our corrupt system what
happens when our corrupt system touches
it with the evaluation by peers in this
case the people who write nature news
they get it wrong right they reveal not
only there's value in the
so-called non-peer-reviewed literature
but that when peers touch it there's
nothing magical about their evaluation
they can botch it they do the same thing
scientists do when they're in a rush
which is they you know assume that what
is reported in the title in the abstract
is actually what is uh suggested by the
paper so anyway the whole thing is kind
of revealing itself it is and um it's a
it's it's a pity you have to know where
the bodies are buried in order to see
what's being acknowledged and what's
being botched
um because really everybody needs to be
uh exposed to the evidence that peer
review is not a magical process it's a
corrupt process and it's a flawed
process even even when it works it's a
deeply flawed process and it is so
corrupt as to be counterproductive in
many contexts indeed
so just a couple more things on um on
this here and the accumulation on my
screen if you'd like is the other
preprint referred to in that nature news
article this is
uh this has as the first author who was
the guy that was the second author I
think it's a guy
uh from that other paper and it is
titled duration of immune protection of
SARS Kobe 2 natural infection against
reinfection and cutter
and this uh this I assessed actually
less completely than I did the first
article uh and so I'm not going to make
claims as to uh as to how well done this
particular research was it's a lot it's
a lot more sticky with regard to the
statistics that they use but here is a
line from I think it's the discussion
this is just my PDF version of that same
article
this waning and natural immunity mirrors
that of vaccine immunity but at a slower
rate vaccine immunity May last for only
a year but natural immunity assuming
gumpert's Decay May last for three years
so
this is one of the first times if not
the first time that I've seen an
acknowledgment of natural immunity being
Superior to vaccine-induced immunity in
the scientific literature
um
there I believe it has been described it
is very contentious and not widely
accepted but I believe it's been
described elsewhere
I'm struggling with whether or not
they're conflating two things
right there
vaccine immunity
should be expected to wane because it's
crappy immunity right even to the extent
that we talk about it in terms of
antibodies they're not the core of a
robust immune response they're easily
measured and that's why we focus on them
they're easily measured and frankly to
the extent that you want to manipulate
the public the public has some idea what
an antibody is or at least that they're
important and they don't really know
what a T cell is so
um so the point is we've focused on them
but it's it's a feeble kind of immunity
and therefore you might expect that
because the immune system does not
depend on us typically for uh for
immunity to viruses to which you've been
exposed that the short-lived antibody
response might Wane rapidly and to the
extent That vaccine manufacturers tap
into the antibody response as their
mechanism for preventing disease that it
would Wane rapidly because it doesn't
have the proper characteristics for
long-term durable immunity that's one
phenomenon the failure of the immunity
that was generated by The Experience if
you got sick your immunity was more
durable than if you got vaccinated okay
but the other thing
um has to do with the evolution of the
pathogen right right and so the the
which you know this team was looked like
they were trying to sort that out in the
first paper I was talking about but then
when you look at their methods you find
that they actually just used a date you
know a moment in time before and after
which was their proxy for variance which
is which is not acceptable it's not
evidence yes yes it is assumption is the
problem it's it is an assumption
masquerading is evidence right and
that's a No-No that's a big one yeah um
but so I don't know I don't know what to
do with the fact that you've got these
two you know to say that the immunity
wanes may even be technically true but
is it you know you could get that if you
had perfectly static levels of antibody
immunity and the pathogen evolved away
so that they were less and less well
tuned that would cause the observed
phenomenon of less and less uh
Effectiveness so is part of what you're
going after here is and what
what does immunity wanes mean you have
antibody versus T Cell but let's put
that aside for the moment for the moment
you also have
your immunity to the thing you were
exposed to waned or has the thing you
were exposed to become so such a
minority representative in the
population of this broad lineage of
viruses
such that while that original immunity
that you got from an older lineage may
still help a little bit with anything
you would be exposed to in modern times
it's not that your immune system
forgot what it knew it's that it is now
being exposed to something that didn't
exist before not only that and this I
think is where the rubber meets the road
for a lot of this
there is a question that haunts our
entire coveted response
would we be better off if we had done
nothing
right now that's not the only question
we had other things to do that were not
these vaccines right but had we done
nothing would we be better off today
than we are today given what we did in
which case you don't want to do the kind
of thing we did right now I don't think
we can answer that question I think uh I
have a strong suspicion but the basic
point is if you if you're
stupid narrowly targeted vaccine-like
substance that you have transfected
people with if that thing is simply
pushing around an evolutionary ninja
right right if you have come at like a
ninja with plastic Cutlery right and the
ninja is
right exactly if that's what we're doing
right and the point is you know we are
training the ninja what we can see by
coming at it with a plastic knife that
can't possibly work and right it's just
a mistake and I mean you actually then
arrive us at what was what was going to
be my final Point here
um well
which is
how dare they why are we in this
position at all like we're not I'm not
talking about vaccines at this point I'm
talking about you know
[Music]
who gave anyone the right to create this
ninja in the first place right okay
what if we had done nothing in March
2020 when this thing had emerged how
about what if we had done nothing in
March 2010 I'm making that number up I
have no idea when gain of function
research was in its early nascent stages
and some people thought it was really
great and we're putting together lots of
justifications because that's what you
need to do and they started to buy their
own press and they started to create
these things which have escaped from
their damn bottles and there's no
putting this Genie back in no there's
just there's there's the the bottle is
gone the genie is out here we're all
stuck with it and now they're just
adding you know injury to injury yeah
injury to injury is right yeah there's
to the extent that it has become quite
clear that this came from the lab and
even in the tiny remaining chance that
it did not that it certainly could have
right if if this didn't if this came
from the wet Market the fact that there
was a laboratory whatever it is 14
kilometers away uh turbo charging
exactly the sort of virus without the
ability to prevent a leak means is it
gonna be the ferret Badger popsicles
again
yeah ferret Badger popsicles uh again is
is right but to the extent that we did
everything necessary to create this
insane condition and probably did create
this insane condition right this should
be a a an absolute focus and yet
we
so many of us are aware but the usual
process by which the public becoming
aware that something terrible and
needless has befall in it right would
usually trigger a response that we just
don't see
foreign
[Music]